pour démarrer on va parler du démarchage
téléphonique 72 % des Français disent
être appelés au moins une fois par
semaine et 38 % tous les jours une
pratique envahissante et qui agace alors
savez-vous comment vous en prémunir nous
vous avons posé la question sur nos
réseaux sociaux et vous êtes 69 % à
répondre non or normalement la loi
oblige les entreprises démarcheuses à
indiquer la possibilité de s'inscrire
sur une liste d'opposition au démarchage
téléphonique pour ne plus recevoir ses
appels une réglementation qui que n'a
pas respecté notamment l'entreprise
green patrimoine à veignier on vous le
disait hier la direction départemental
de la protection des populations
d'indréloire vient de lui infliger une
grosse amende pour démchage illégal plus
d'explications avec lat
turquy près de 382000 € c'est le montant
de l'amende administrative prononcé par
la préfecture d'indréloir ce lundi à
l'encontre de l'entreprise green
patrimoine pour démarchage téléphonique
illégale une pratique répandue
aujourd'hui qui touche une grande partie
des tourangeau donc je ne décroche pas
sauf des fois je me fais avoir si
c'était une
fois tous les de jours ESS mais là ça
arrive jusqu'à 5 ou si fois par jour
souvent ça m'arrive souvent des numéros
qui viennent du sud ou même de
l'étranger puis on termine tout
simplement par les bloquer il y a les
téléphones portables ont un petit signal
ce qui fait que ça limite les les dégâts
quand je vois que c'est je m'excuse et
j'arrête la conversation l'entreprise
basée à veignier a écopé d'une lourde
amende pour plusieurs raisons selon la
préfecture la principale un démarchage
téléphonique dans le but de proposer la
vente d'équipement ou de travaux en vue
de réaliser des économies d'énergie ce
qui est interdit par la loi un
manquement de l'information
précontractuelle du consommateur a
également été souligné alors les
obligations légales en matière de
démarchage c'est premièrement la
prohibition de percevoir une quelconque
somme avant un délai de 7 jours et le
consommateur a un délai de 14 jours pour
se rétracter et dénoncer le contrat la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations d'indréloire
a été alertée suite au signalement des
consommateurs sur la plateforme du
gouvernement signale conso un site
internet permettant à tous d'indiquer à
l'état des problèmes rencontrés avec
certaines entreprises et notamment le
démarchage abusif donc ce dossier c'est
des mois d'enquête pour en lien avec le
niveau national et ce que je peux
préciser c'est qu'il y a une autre
enquête en cours et que il y a d'autres
sociétés du même type de démarchag qui
sont dans le collimateur des services de
l'État la préfecture d'indrloir précise
également que l'entreprise n'a pas
indiqué au consommateurs la possibilité
de s'inscrire sur une liste d'opposition
au démarchage
téléphonique